what are the things that people
shouldn't Outsource nothing you can
Outsource whatever you want I think it's
just what goals do you have if you love
painting and your whole business is
painting as soon as you hire painters
you're no longer painting anymore is
that what you wanted some people yeah
some people know the difference is if a
painter wants to make money painting
that is different than somebody wanting
to start a painting business one is a
business career the other is a
Technician career and that's actually a
really big one a lot of people who are
technicians love the craft and hate the
business and they need to decide whether
they want to be business people or they
want to be technicians and I don't think
there's a right or wrong answer they
just need to decide for themselves and
then stop their expectations about
having both because the businessman
wishes he could paint all day painter
wishes he could make the money the
businessman